we don't like you one bit Voldemort but
if we had to choose between hanging out
with you or Dolores Umbridge we would
choose you any day that woman is so vile
she could make anyone's skin crawl a
dark dungeon filled with Death Eaters
sounds like a lemon drop compared to a
bright pink office filled with cat
pictures and enchanted quills on bridge
is such a despicable character it's easy
to forget that she's a funny and decent
person in real life even movie
franchises as magical and serious as
Harry Potter have blooper reels of their
own it can be strange to see villains
like Voldemort's on rich and draco
malfoy laughing between takes but that's
exactly what you're about to see watch
until the end to find out which scene on
bridge and McGonagall couldn't film
without laughing Hermione Granger isn't
someone who beats around the bush while
we wouldn't go as far as to call her
violent she has delivered her fair share
of blows throughout the franchise and
we're not talking about that time she
punched Draco Malfoy in the face and
Harry Potter and the Prisoner of Azkaban
nope we're talking about the time she
hit Harry in the head with a roll of
parchment paper in Harry Potter and the
half-blood Prince in this scene Hermione
points out that a girl is only
interested in Harry because she thinks
he's the chosen one to which Harry
replies but I am the chosen one
that's when Hermione unleashes her wrath
upon the Boy Who Lived
this scene makes for one of the funniest
bloopers in the film before the actors
perfected the scene Emma Watson
accidentally hit Daniel Radcliffe a
little too hard
prompting her to start laughing
uncontrollably Daniel had to cut his
line short and asked her if she was
laughing because of how hard she hit him
and he was right on the money
Draco Malfoy has hated Harry Potter ever
since he chose Ron Weasley over him and
Harry Potter and the Sorcerer's Stone
since then he's tried to one-up him
every step of the way when Harry made
seeker in the first year of Hogwarts
draco retaliated by buying his way into
the Slytherin Quidditch team in his
second year filming the Quidditch
matches wasn't always easy tom felton
and Daniel had to sit on suspended
broomsticks in front of a blue screen
and things got a little heated every
once in a while while filming the iconic
Quidditch match of Harry Potter and the
Chamber of Secrets Tom and Daniel
playfully bickered when it came to their
placements when Tom pointed out that
Daniel had gone the wrong way
Daniel replied whoops but Tom thought
that Daniel was calling him a was this
hilarious bloopers had the crew laughing
in no time
although Harry Andrew Coyne might be
enemies on screen that the boys pointed
out that they're quite chummy in real
life Daniel Radcliffe was just 11 years
old when he first started shooting Harry
Potter and the Sorcerer's Stone and like
most of the kid actors on set Dana had
issues with keeping a straight face
during some serious scenes there are
tons of bloopers from the first film but
none compared to how Daniel reacted to
being yelled at by actor Verne Troyer
who portrayed the Goblin Griphook when
Hagrid first takes Harry to Gringotts he
surprised to find out that goblins exist
in the actual film Griphook asks harry
but at first Griphook was supposed to
yell at young Harry before asking him
for his key problem was Dana Radcliffe
couldn't stop himself from bursting into
laughter after being yelled at by Vern
so the scene was altered to prevent the
young actors outburst producers wanted
Harry to look startled by the goblins
tree but their initial vision just
didn't translate well on camera summer
as they come goblin without the most
friendly of beasts
actor Warwick Davis is the actor behind
the lovable charms master at Hogwarts
but even someone as serious as Professor
Flitwick was bound to have fun while on
the set of Harry Potter and the Goblet
of Fire
during the Yule Ball Professor Flitwick
is seen conducting the Hogwarts choir
while the students waltz their way
across the dance floor but things get a
little hectic when the weird sisters
take the stage
causing the students to pick up
Professor Flitwick and pass him over
their heads
this crowd surfing scene is unexpected
and hilarious especially since Flitwick
can be heard yelling and his students to
put him down but the bloopers are even
funnier than the actual footage in the
blooper reel we see the students passing
Warwick to one another but the actor
stops them by asking this got a good
laugh out of everyone the crew members
included keep watching to find out which
cast member got pranks by Michael Gambon
and the late Alan Rickman any of you are
surely wondering why I have summoned you
at this what are the funniest scenes
from Harry Potter and the Deathly
Hallows Part one has got to be when
Harry's friends take a Polyjuice potion
with Harry's hair in it they do this to
confuse the Death Eaters who are on the
prowl for the Boy Who Lived
this scene was filmed in front of a
green screen to facilitate the
transformations but in the end
Daniel had to pretend to be six
different versions of his on-screen
counterparts Daniel pointed out that he
was most excited to dress up as Fleur
Delacour because he thought that he
looked wonderful in women's clothes due
to how hilarious the scene was the cast
had to film multiple takes resulting in
a blooper reel
Daniel had to wear a bra and pretend to
be floor but handling this female
undergarment proved to be most difficult
Daniel had to ask for help taking off
his bra seeing as he was supposed to
take it off in one swift motion
luckily floors on-screen husband bill
came to Daniel's rescue
really easily
according to Minerva McGonagall the Yule
Ball is of course a chance for us all to
let our hair down and this was very much
the case for actor tom Felton who spent
years dying and slicking his hair back
to portray the draco malfoy tom did let
his hair down to bust a move or two with
his cast mates but strictly behind the
scenes of course while preparing to film
the ghoul ball scenes in Harry Potter
and the Goblet of Fire the actors who
portrayed the students had to learn how
to dance the waltz perfecting the dance
took about three weeks to do but even
then Tom didn't feel all that
comfortable there are tons of bloopers
of the cast messing up their steps but
one of the most surprising bloopers
places tom felton and emma watson
together on the dance floor Hermione and
Draco would never share a dance in the
Wizarding World so this scene is a lot
of fun to watch especially since we know
that Emma was crushing on Tom while
filming the movies in Harry Potter and
the Deathly Hallows Part 1 to go in trio
visits Luna Lovegood father Xenophilius
to get some information on the Deathly
Hallows what they don't know however is
that Xenophilius has ratted them out to
try and save Luna who's being held
captive by the Dark Lord's followers
this scene is very serious and dark so
it's hard to believe that Rupert Grint
Daniel Radcliffe Emma Watson and Rhys Oh
Wayne Evans had a hard time keeping a
straight face while filming it
according to Rhys who plays Lunas dad
Emma couldn't keep it together and each
time she laughed or ruined to take she
was fined by producers every time they
slurped their tea Emma would start
giggling which would make everyone laugh
considering the nature of the scene were
surprised that Emma couldn't keep her
cool but either way the actors managed
to deliver an amazing performance
giggles and all well well it's the sign
of the Deathly Hollows of course
one of the funniest bloopers happened
while filming Harry Potter and the
Prisoner of Azkaban well that is if you
can count it as a blooper after all it
was more of a prank and let's just say
that the Boy Wonder was the butt of the
joke Alan Rickman and Michael Gambon who
played Severus Snape and Albus
Dumbledore respectively joined forces to
prank Daniel in one of the most
unsuspected ways the prank happened
while the students of Hogwarts were
forced to sleep on the floor in the
Great Hall in the movie this happens
after the fat lady is defaced by the
escaped convict Sirius Black who is said
to be at large in the castle but before
filming the scene Michael and Alan put a
fart machine in Daniels sleeping bag and
Michael proceeded to press the button
while saying his lines this hilarious
blooper add the entire grade hall in
shambles unfortunately for Daniel he was
sleeping near a girl he fancied which
made the prank even more effective we
enter completely our own world the Harry
Potter franchise just wouldn't have been
the same without everyone's favorite
Weasley Ron that actor Rupert grints did
bring his own suitcase of problems to
the set as it turns out Rupert was
notorious for smiling and laughing when
he was not supposed to
which made stain and character all
button possible there are tons of
blooper reels dedicated to rupert alone
in fact he probably smiled and laughed
his way through hours of footage even
Matthew Lewis who played Neville
Longbottom talks about how much Rupert
used to make him laugh during takes
sometimes directors would have to yell
cut
because Rupert was caught grinning in
the background of a very serious scene
Dolores Umbridge is one of the most
despicable characters in the Harry
Potter franchise and no one dislikes her
more than Professor McGonagall but in
real life on bridges portrayed by the
hilarious email de Staton and she and
Maggie Smith aka McGonagall are very
good friends one of the funniest
bloopers takes place in Harry Potter and
the order of the Phoenix
when McGonagall gives unbridgeable oh
these two witches are about to draw
wands but in reality both actors are
having a hard time mastering the scene
because they couldn't stop laughing
turns out unwritten zuv humor and an
excellent singing voice - and that's a
wrap on the top 10 funniest Harry Potter
bloopers before you go tell us which
character is your all-time favorite in
the comment section below give this
video a big thumbs up and be sure to
subscribe to the things for more we'll
catch you next time thanks for watching